[Music]
let's ride
i said let's ride
that's right maybe i'll my thing will be
let's ride okay i like that that's right
that's right let's ride
welcome everybody to leftovers
episode 10.
the civil war is inevitable
we are here to aggregate we want to
um
accelerate the civil war yeah yeah this
is this is the tim pool broadcast ladies
and gentlemen we are here to talk about
the civil war it's inevitable why are
the liberals avoiding it donald trump
won every state donald trump won 52
states actually there's extra states now
and donald trump won them you know
what's awesome bro
is that not only do we know tim bull tim
pool is a sexless uh unlovable
like i don't know if he's a virgin but
there's a chance let's say
you know
but some somehow being like unlevel
unloved by women turned you into like a
civil war craving lunatic i guess we
knew that yeah i think i think that's
there's like two there's two pathways
towards radicalization and both of them
involve women because women are the
problem here okay
uh and one is that being like uh
unlikable unlovable uh person that women
don't want to be around and like
refusing to change your behavior
or even like you know fix things about
yourself and instead blaming feminism
and then the other is divorce court
well
and so i just hear well okay first of
all
divorce court is the number one pipeline
to radicalization
you know what they're the you say that
jokingly but divorce court is kind of
[ __ ] up for dudes
there's certainly some issues with uh
divorce sport
now you got me [ __ ] men's right red
pill let's do it let's do it dude
come on let's do it ethan klein mra i'm
about to [ __ ] be sexless over here
yeah
ela's gonna see me talk about divorce
card stop touching my dick forever
that's how you become a conservative and
then all of a sudden i'm not blowing up
schools yeah oh jesus
okay well anyway you know we knew that
temple was a sexless uh virgin but
there's this other guy and i know this
is coming right at the top but it's so
good nick fuentes
i just i don't even like giving this
dude any [ __ ] exposure to be honest
he's he's a nazi yeah is he oh straight
just straight up no he just like does
like he
there's a lot of those going around
these days just asks questions about
what the hell this is so good no this is
funny because like it kind of shows you
it proves that these young republicans
are they're just the way they are
because they can't get laid bro they
can't it's not that they can't even get
laid it's like women won't even talk to
them because they're so repulsive like
watch nick fuentes
uh
even republican women and this is like
this lady here is already like a
repulsive human
yeah even though she's like you're
disgusting even to me
yeah that's that's how you know you've
lost it like if if like
you know the dollar store version of uh
what's-her-face lauren chen
or uh i guess these people are just like
trying to do their own like laura ingram
universe you know what i mean
if that person don't if that person
doesn't want anything to do with you you
are [ __ ] you're done
well just watch this guys i mean this is
awesome i find it interesting though
that you've only ever lived in the
united states
i just i i just you can only do so much
reading before practical experience
actually should take you know some sort
of precedence and i mean i say the same
thing about women too i mean i dare say
from my understanding of many of your
viewpoints you also promote like the way
of interacting with women and i go have
you been in a relationship with a woman
no
so how are you telling other people how
to behave towards when were you yourself
the actual physical you know interaction
with them
in a romantic capacity or in fact in any
capacity where you you know uphold them
in a way that treats them with respect i
mean if you're out here arguing that
women are basically half the value of
well yeah i'm not gonna put words in
your mouth in fact cause that's not
right
but you know if you are looking to some
other regimes around the world that do
think that women are half the value of a
man i have to question what kind of a
person who's had no experience with
women is in a position to to you know
basically promote these ideas well i'm
having an experience with a woman right
now
sorry i netted already by the way yeah
exactly i just screamed my pants lady
too late it counts i love that i just
love that i'm having an experience with
a woman right now uh yeah and do you say
he's like and i've hang out i have lunch
with my mom on the weekends it's not a
good one you're having an experience not
a good one yeah that's what he's saying
they're all bad yeah when you're you
they're all bad and i've had lots of
experiences with women in my life not
not romantically per se but you know
i've talked to enough women i've been
you know
i've known enough women to know sort of
what's going on i don't get a man who is
observant enough and honestly you know
like i said we could go back to great
geniuses we could go back to people that
have been in relationships like a
perfect example is like the pickup
artists you know have you ever noticed a
pickup artist who have the most no
nobody watched pick-up artists i've
watched pokemons all the time
you know how pick-up art is you watch
pick-up artists too what do you mean
yeah forget for good but like i think
you know the most the most like
he's talking to a woman by the way you
know pick-up artist i think we all like
intentionally avoid that you know you
know she's horned up she's ready to [ __ ]
he's like i i get it he's like his
presence and everything he represents is
already like just a mood killer total
vibe killer in general i feel like
but
once he starts talking about like i know
women and uh i watch pick-up artists all
the time i know what's going on and it's
like
you're just you're never gonna you're
never gonna he's like an
anti-aphrodisiac i think nick fuentes is
the ultimate uh sex killer he is
the
the dryer the everywhere everyone's over
the blow dryer everyone's ovaries dried
the [ __ ] up no periods for everybody
he's like birth control
ovulation stops yeah men become
infertile
around him he's like the great
replacement uh it's like dude yeah why
don't you [ __ ] replace your attitude
i'll tell you who i'll tell you i'll
tell you what's gonna be replaced
all the pop i mean all the people of the
world without his offspring because he
ain't getting laid that's true that's
right
sorry you know i don't i mean dude your
last name is fuentes you're hispanic
and you're a nazi that's just it's a
walking contradiction
most relationships with women and the
most sex
they what they say is that really with
women it's the same bag of tricks
uh to seduce a woman or whatever and i
think that kind of tells you something
about the nature of women that you know
you go from woman to woman oh my god
okay okay he he literally went from
i know women i've talked to plenty i'm
talking to one right now
and also i watch a lot of pickup artists
and you know they always run the same
bag of tricks it's like this dude watch
40 year old virgin and thinks that's how
you're supposed to like you know date
dude nick if it's so easy
if picking up chicks is so [ __ ] easy
why are you a virgin bro
well he's he's celibate before mary is
she is he you think he's uh he's in uh
involuntary celeb celibacy isn't that
insane though yeah yeah well that's what
i'm always wondering it's like why
aren't you reproducing like you should
be living in a [ __ ] commune and and
like making as many well you're hispanic
maybe that's why because he's a
self-hating uh hispanic nazi so he's
just like well i can't technically have
people i can't technically have
offspring because i would also be
diluting the racial
right
i'm working on getting myself deported
like little tricks little things you
could say or whatever so do it hack them
and whatever and i think that kind of
says it all about their names
it says it all it says it all when you
think [ __ ] pickup artists and like
watching pickup artists is a is a great
way to accurately and adequately assess
how women are like
i mean it says more about uh the i mean
pickup artistry is one of the lowest
forms of uh
male expression it is just just a total
creep show you're you're literally the
you are like the the documentarian yeah
koji documentarian of pickup artistry
dude bro i've been studying these guys
there's they are hold on i want to show
you
andrew's video on pickup artists just to
see
who he's talking about these [ __ ]
guys are the girl well probably this is
the guy he's talking about
ultimately we think it's the girls we
think it's the time i met that guy
i love these guys this guy has the world
record for the most people he's made out
with five thousand that's cool making
her sick yeah
especially with the with that that's why
he's got the he's got the lip guard
yeah you see that do you think that
keeps like the
way yeah it's like it's like it's like a
bumper for you know how the cop cars
have that because they're supposed to
bump into people that's why he has that
he like he deflects uh he deflects women
that desire him with the bumpers like
no i will not be kissing you
well
there is just a really interesting
parallel between these nazi creeps and
just not being able to uh have female
companionship
and uh
i think it's something that we need to
study and be aware of yeah well
that's what is like so frustrating about
someone like jordan peterson for example
which is like
they go from a lot of these dudes are
suffering for sure okay i'm not gonna
sit here and just be like you're not not
nick frances i'm talking about like the
average you know
pasty frail white kid on the internet
uh who thinks you know
who who doesn't have future prospects
lined up
recognizes deep down inside that like
our our their future is not going to be
the same as like their parents right
it's gonna be much harder for them to
get a house meaningful fulfilling
employment things of that nature
and that that is constantly eating away
at them and then on top of that they're
like constantly on the internet feeling
extra alienated but then they hyper
focus on these communities that tell
them like hey we'll help you out and
it's actually the system that's the
fault like but not capitalism or not
anything like that but the system is uh
at fault because of feminism and if you
went to a trad cath lifestyle then you
would be able to you know have a good
trad cath wife who will cook for you and
you know you'll have like your own
version of an arranged marriage or
whatever what they fail to recognize is
the pareto principle the 20 percent of
men get 80 of women burrito principle
right a lot of these uh pua people use
still applies in a nazi utopia
dystopia
utopia
yeah
but like hans is gonna [ __ ] all the trad
cath ladies i'm just saying
like even if it's not
uh a brown dude like you that's the
thing about the the incels they also
want like they demand and require ten
out of tens only they only want the most
beautiful women in the world
but let me tell you something
jordan peterson had a extremely based
take recently oh yeah
yeah dude and you know we're critical of
our boy jordan so i want to give him a
fair shake on the show today he [ __ ]
called out in cells recently and it was
very epic okay
um
it's kind of quiet here dan
has no desire
for the average male and that because of
things like social media okay that dude
on the left definitely sells crypto
that's that's
right
i see dudes like this all the time on
the internet i'm like that's that's a
crypto maximalist you know what i mean
that's what he does
for sure on the side
jordan peterson's calling in some
interesting shows though
the roommates look up see if you can
confirm if that means crypto dude you
should have him back on
but with me it doesn't look that good
either oh i that would be awesome i
don't think he would come and talk to
you that's the thing no i don't think
because jordan's always like i i'm i'm
i'm only
i'm only described as right-wing because
they're the only ones that will talk to
me
but i would love to see you debate him i
would i would love to have a comment i
think he hates my guts now though with
dr peterson i would i would yeah we need
to have jordan peterson on and then we
both do his voice the entire time while
we're talking to him like listen doctor
i've watched so many of your videos and
that's why i talk like this is true is
literally why i i have the jordan
peterson voice like
it's a pure purely out of love and
dedication to you doctor
[Laughter]
all right here we go
watch this bass to ask peterson along
those lines as well as just some of the
female empowerment where a lot of women
have a some this is what they say an
elevated sense of self that that that
now they feel like they're above a lot
of these average men um i would say to
young men who are irritated at women
is if you're irritated at women you know
as a class of creature there's something
wrong with you because they're right
you're wrong
they're right oh to not pick you if
they're not picking you it's because
they're right
now what do you expect from women
if you got pregnant because you had sex
you'd be pretty damn choosy too
so you know clue in a bit that's a great
[ __ ] that's a base tank he's like if
you're gonna get pregnant from one of
these dead beats you'd be picky too
[ __ ] you red-pilled [ __ ] it's it's
like a very
so
it's it's still a very interestingly
like biology
yeah it's still not that well because
technically the reason the real reason
why like
uh you know women are picky is because
everyone's picky people always say this
yeah i was literally talking about this
yesterday on my stream last night uh
when i was looking at my favorite pickup
artist of course because that's what i
do i love pick-up artists oh oh yeah
specific wine uh fresh and fit was what
we were diving into uh fresh and fit
yeah he probably [ __ ] with the name
like that yeah there's two two of them
and there was one
and then like ran into their [ __ ]
studio apparently it happens regularly
because dj academics was there anyway
wait is one fresh and one fit
i think so oh i don't know which one's
fresh and fit though which one's fake
because like they both look not very
fresh but they both look pretty fit okay
um
so
i was watching that and you know of
course in the chat as there always is
there were some [ __ ] people that were
like
like
you know you can't talk on this like
women only want to [ __ ] you you are a
desirable man and it's like i was
thinking i was like
okay well do you want to [ __ ]
undesirable women like have you ever
been like
oh yeah i really want to have someone i
really want sex with someone who i find
to be unattractive beauty is subjective
okay it can be physical
and it can come from within but it's
like
impossible you're not the one to be
delivering this message okay
you say yeah yeah okay okay let's stop
with the beauty of subjective [ __ ] when
everyone's scrapping your ass okay okay
my point is this though my point is this
it's like
of course uh women are going to want to
be with people that they find desirable
yes you want to be men
it's ironic men are way are pickier than
women women [ __ ] settle down look at
me dude women settle all day and we love
them for that women are the ultimate
settlers
men aren't said i just saw kyle i just
saw kyle rittenhouse on tucker being
like i need a girl with the tiny waist
and big titties
kyle you're famous for killing people
bro what are you [ __ ] talking about
yeah you're not ella you're what is
eligible about you you literally just
kill people
yeah he's um that's so like he's gonna
find it he's gonna you know you're right
guys
he likes butts
i like big books i like butt
[Laughter]
yeah kyle rittenhouse
tucker goes what kind of lady are you in
are you single
i was like guys this guy just killed
people and that's why he's famous let's
just let's not make a hero
out of him but
you know what there's probably a lot of
not tucker by the way
oh that was wrong yeah he was on top he
was on tucker too
yeah crowder
right anyway here's here's jordan
kind of i would say can you red pillow
he's blue pilling a red pill
i like that yeah oh [ __ ]
they find you attractive well maybe
you're not maybe you're okay cannot be
angry at women
it's stupid women
it's like
that's
it's like women being angry at men
it's a sign of psychological
trouble that
i like that i'm not saying that this is
easy but i'm saying that
it's a useful reaction
what else are you gonna do
what else are you gonna do complain
about women
you have to particularize your problem
why can't men find women to date
that's not your problem because you're
you're fat love everybody who can't work
at mcdonald's the woman you want
and you you have to assume that's your
problem because otherwise you have to
assume that it's the women's problem and
really they're all wrong and you're
right really this is brilliant to you
exactly i saw this on tick tock and i
was like making a turn is that is the
oil money drying up or something what's
that it was real interesting because
like the incels are his bread and butter
like desperate young men that these are
who these are who he served so when i
saw this i was like [ __ ] base jordan
yeah he's on the left over his pockets
he's like the left is actually rising up
we should seize the means of
production
i've always been fascinated with ussr
iconography for a reason because lenin
was based
uh by the way this uh gentleman i i
can't find any evidence that he sells
crypto i'm afraid
what does he do he's gonna have
self-help or something yeah you nailed
it okay okay masculinity 10 steps to
healthy manhood well dude um
for only 20 bucks let's just talk to
jordan
pay in full or for free interest
installments
you can order between 50 and 3 000 what
the [ __ ] you selling dude
the truth that's what can we buy this
for 20 bucks and just look at it dude
the problem is like every man wants to
be successful but not every man is
willing to put in the work and sacrifice
by signing up for 10 steps to healthy
manhood along with masculinity course
you'll also become part of an elite one
percent of men who take tangible steps
to achieve their dreams one percent
where do you get that this course will
walk you through and provide you the
foundation it will give you the tools
and you will be able to
physically and metaphorically um
restrain women against their will
well so the thing though that jordan
peterson is absolutely correct on and
that i can't believe i'm agreeing with
ivan 100 is that like
yeah i do
i do believe that self-improvement goes
a long way
i always joke about this but it's like
every guy can be a seven okay as a
starting point i hate like the rating
system obviously but you know what i
mean right locally understanding yeah
actually understanding like everyone
could be a seven figure out what kind of
hair works on the top of your head maybe
that's bald okay maybe that's fully
shaved maybe that's a jason statham
style you know buzz um by the way it's
funny i'm saying this because i don't
think my hair looks good right now but
it's fine uh think about what kind of
like
beard works for you every guy can be a
seven
i think every guy can be a seven
if they figure out those things
groom themselves adequately okay
and that includes of course taking a
[ __ ] shower daily you think every day
hit the weights yeah
what about this guy what are you gonna
what are you gonna show me [ __ ] hat
and jersey in the pool bro
this guy's a seven i think he could be a
seven
i think i i mean it i think this guy i
think that man i mean he would have to
like dramatically change his personality
because like
you know and and shave that like that's
the pro oh my god and shave that fake
beard that he has on that looks like
it's it's pixelated the problem with
well
nick fuentes seems like in decent shape
and he's not like a terrible looking
dude it's just his personality his dog
[ __ ]
yeah
like he's just
so repulsive
um and you know who else do you think
every guy can be a seven look at this
pig vomit okay you can't show harvey
weinstein again on the broadcast dude
you've been doing that yeah look at this
you've been [ __ ] guy wait that's not
harvey weinstein wait a minute kavanagh
wait a minute dude
i'm going to call him pig [ __ ]
it's a howard stern thing but you know
why i call him pig [ __ ] why because he
looks like a pig and he makes me want to
[ __ ]
okay that's good
he looks kind of beefy there yeah almost
like 70. okay yeah and look rich
so but that's the point is [ __ ] the
point is that like you definitely can
take steps to improve yourself and
through that uh journey of improving
yourself you will
get more confident
like i've gone through a similar process
in my life as well where i
was very overweight and like terrified
and had a lot of social anxiety and all
that sort of thing
this just showed up on google images
every time i think of ryan kevin i think
his business partner alleging he was
involved in a ponzi scheme
i didn't say that you did i'm just
reading your tweet man what are you
doing are you just trying to get me out
of this lawsuit yeah what a [ __ ] i'm
a cav head okay i went to a party last
night at the at the dog pound gym and
there's some tic tac boys there and one
of them was wearing a trailer jacket
was gonna take a photo of it and send it
off
i can't believe people actually wrapped
trailer well they pay a lot of people i
don't know how their pockets are so deep
man this is directly yeah his earnings
his earnings from all the lawsuits well
he didn't earn anything yet he spent a
lot he's milking those wikipedia editors
dry dude
there's some dude in his mouth bro for
all that [ __ ] anyway um i totally agree
you know i totally agree
um everything else is outside your
control which is what jordan's saying
and that's what's that's what's the
important thing you can only do what you
can do which is
be healthy
get a good [ __ ] job educate yourself
be kind if you're not funny if you're
not charming at least be kind that's it
that's that's all yeah that's it that's
all you can do be kind and don't be
entitled because a lot of people are
like they just genuinely feel like well
i'm a good guy i'm a nice guy why aren't
these [ __ ] into me and then it's like
well you're not a nice guy then but it's
kind of like jordan said if you really
believe that i feel like it is a symptom
of like a serious mental uh
yeah there's some there's something
going on that's not right
but yeah i mean it's it's not hard and
you know
listen
it's gonna be fine bro you're gonna
you're gonna be fine you don't need to
shoot up to school okay
wow
wise words from ethan klein but you know
the two if a kid's shooting up at school
it's definitely their parents fault i
mean how do you must be [ __ ] your kid
up bro oh yeah if a high school kid
wants to shoot up at school
it's the parents fall a hundred percent
of the time
yeah he's getting [ __ ] by his parents
i agree for sure
um yeah like the the michigan
one is like directly the [ __ ] well i've
never heard that in all the school
shootings is that we've lived through it
where the parents just bail they're like
uh yeah this is all right that was not
like it's our fault we're bailing
yeah they like they don't well they
bought him a gun two days before for his
birthday and he's like thank you mommy
and daddy
well they bought him a gun tuesday uh
two days before the shooting on black
friday they got him a six hour oh they
got my black friday deal yeah hell yeah
nice you know good good for them you
know i'm a deal seeker myself
um i wonder if the bullets were on
discount too well that's the actually
interesting part that like he was
looking for bullets at school
he was like okay
reported that he was looking for
ammunition at school and the teachers
heard that and teachers reported that to
the principal and the principal like
obviously you know called his parents
and told him about it
and the mom's text message from the mom
is like i'm not mad just don't get
caught next time
it's kind of hard to get not get caught
when you kill yeah five people at your
school yeah and she's like oh [ __ ] time
to not get caught we're bouncing down
they like bailed they bailed so quick
they went to like some [ __ ] they got
caught in like some warehouse in detroit
it's awesome like some army it's
terrible but you know yeah [ __ ]
amazing how they knew they were so
[ __ ] guilty but anyway back to base
jordan peterson you are you're an
undiscovered gem of some sort
probably not
level in a communal level but
fundamentally it's like
and you do so so much less harm if you
look to yourself first as the problem
beth and believe me you're plenty of
problem for you that's you're all the
problem you need for you that's for sure
i think it's important where'd you come
from
oh there's a little uh editorial eyes
out there
for us to share our opinions and
interpretation
girl i have no idea what your
involvement on this video is but we love
you for that um
actually actually good video from uh
jordan uh this is like his basics he's
back to doing like the self-help stuff
which he's
he he was undeniably decent at at least
or very good yeah he's good
and and for me i feel like that's all
it's a template it's a basic template
that they're following you know fix
yourself up with small steps clean your
room bucko um but it is helpful get it
get a [ __ ] penis stretcher for
christ's sake it'll add three inches
is that true
i don't know
[Applause]
actually i think what a well like a get
a penis pump bucko that little [ __ ]
ain't getting you anywhere
they can't get into that stage they
gotta they like i said yeah that's the
final stage yeah clean yourself work out
it'll it'll give you advantage of your
body and health your mind if you manage
to get a girl back at your apartment
take 10 minutes in the bathroom and
get pumping buckle rub one out before
you go don't ever don't don't ever go
out with a loaded gun right
it'll mess up your mind you got to get
that poison out of your system but i
feel like jordan peterson would be a
semi-retention guy like i i feel like
i mean i don't know if he's ever talked
about no fat but i could see it
yeah you gotta retain your semen
yeah
these ladies they want your cummies you
gotta keep the [ __ ] to yourself yeah you
gotta make em earn it bucko
once a year that's how often i come
oh my god jordan peterson does have no
fap uh come on no way
on dave rubin of all places
i love that this guy ripped it and then
just put logic view because that's not
on the tv right it's a watermark it's
not even the name of the channel yeah no
he's just
he's just like we're like yeah i'm the
one who logicview is the one who ripped
this video i gotta hear him on nofap but
see this is 2018. this was when he was
down the meme hole so far i think he's
you know he's had his apple cider scare
and he's crawling back
yeah i don't know where where this fits
on the benzo timeline but
you know he's
there was a
moment
uh where he was just like always sweaty
like he always looked like he was
sweating and i suspect it was the meat
sweats
right
i swear when he was on our show dan he
wasn't that bad he wasn't like so lost
in the sauce
um
yeah i mean like we talked about last
week uh it it wasn't until pretty deep
into the interview that he started
veering off into the cultural marxism
stuff that i even raised an eyebrow at
him because i wasn't familiar at all and
yeah like hassan was saying he
was just a a self-help guy it was my
perspective he's telling ghost stories
and [ __ ] he was talking about like he
leaves him ghosts he hit the mega vape
yeah he hit the mega vape all right
let's watch i want to see what no fat
keep that semen in bucko free and widely
available pornography
is having on young people especially
it's like treasure island
we're all turning into donkeys well
i think it it's like treasure island in
in pinocchio it's all pleasure with no
responsibility that's deadening it's
it's it's parasitical in a sense and i
don't mean that i'm not
making a value judgment i mean it's no
wonder the young guys are caught up in
this because it's an unbelievably
powerful technology it it drew up the
development of the internet let's not
forget right so it taps into one
viciously primordial motivation and so
these guys are being blasted you know
just cause
it you know jordan peterson watches porn
all [ __ ] day these guys who are like
porn is evil they sit and jerk off all
day they got socks crustier than the
damn [ __ ]
than my mom's pie crust
you nut in socks is that you're you're a
sock nutter i've never i mean it's
happened but it's not something i'm
proud of or that i do regularly i have a
paper towel by my like a roll paper
towel by my bedside you've nut into a
paper towel yeah how many rolls how many
paper towels just rip one of the part
one at a time it's very it's very
effective what's your load is like
[ __ ]
it's like a squirt gun i mean how do you
keep that on one paper towel it's hard
but
perfection i hate by the way from a
thousand hours yeah yeah yeah it's
called mastery
mastering the
master debate you know
i just the thing about the paper towel
or the tissue whatever is that i hate
when i
get it on my hands because then the
cleanup process is just waves you just
wash it
yeah i just get weird because then i
touch stuff and i feel bad about like
someone else is going to touch this and
touch my jizz now by proxy and i feel
weird about it
who's like is someone picking up your
like if you have a cleaning person in
your house like are they just going into
your trash isn't it just like in a trash
bag no for example let's say
let's say for example
that um
i'm getting this i've gone off i'm just
yeah it's okay i'm just thinking
let's say i
jerk off
into a tissue in the morning or a paper
towel and you know it gets all over my
hands
and then i go get ready for work okay
and i start and you know i guess you
wash your hands and stuff but i feel
like my hands are still a little nutty
after i wash them you got that you know
you got that you got that viscous no
it's just i know it was there and it's
so vile that i don't want anyone have to
ever
touch it even if they don't know that
you know
and so like i got a little knot on your
hands and then well maybe before you go
wash your hands you you got to bring
take your dirty clothes and put it in
the hamper
okay
you are thinking
wow and then maybe you're not thinking
enough you got to be more considerate of
what what jerking off into a paper towel
interacting with that [ __ ] you know what
i mean dog is like probably smelling
[ __ ] on a regular basis but you've seen
how dogs get like interested in nut it's
disgusting
they do like they do if you put a tissue
like if you're not in a tissue and put
it on the counter your dog's gonna want
to eat that and that i can't live with
no you can't do that yeah yeah no
i can't live with that yeah that's why
you
don't leave him on the counter ethan
well not like overnight what are you
doing like
okay let's say this you've not where do
you put the tissue you get up
immediately and throw it out no i
no it's not just a nut bin i'm a fatty i
like to eat in bed you don't eat in bed
no i got like little treats that i
haven't been again you're living that
single life bro so imagine that there's
a biological stimulus that has an effect
on you and then you can magnify it
and the the typical porn actress
not the amateurs but the professionals
right
riley reed for example is my favorite
he's a man of fight i do not watch the
amateur stuff i think the lighting is
not good enough for me to come
what are you doing half the time i'm
thinking to myself i do not want to see
the male's anus this camera angle is not
conducive
when i see a man's hairy anus and his
balls slapping it just doesn't do it for
me buckle buckle
yeah i don't want to see a man's anus
that is not good pornography purchase a
ring light bucko that's why i watch the
professional stuff with lisa and
all right i actually i don't think he
actually addressed nofap but i think
he's just talking about how porn is bad
and then all these incels just made a
clip of it yeah
kind of fun though go ahead
kind of physical elements exaggerated
and so men are very visual in terms of
their sexual processing um and so you
know the guys are pulled into it and
they're pulled into it also by curiosity
but i think that ethically it's a
it's a
it's it's not good it's not good it's
it's an easy out that's the other thing
you know
what you should be doing is going out
and finding someone to have a
relationship with
and if you can
gratify yourself
with no transformation but let's say you
can't find someone well then you might
say that's an indication you should
change
it is in fact an indication that you
should change because
what better indication are you going to
get than that no one wants to be
intimate with you
it's the ultimate rejection
and i understand that
um dave rubin's brain is a [ __ ] is as
empty as outer the deepest regions of
space so yeah it sounds pretty good
right right he's just like in his mind
he's just thinking like i think a lot of
people will watch this it's great
awesome yeah
all right [ __ ] this they're not doing no
foul yeah i mean
you want to do let's talk about liver
king [ __ ] all this hell yes the real
doctor so we talked live right finally
that primal medicine yeah we talked last
week about the liver king who by the way
we're in contact with to come on the
show
this guy of course he's he's he's on
that he's on that primal grind
and he says we got in touch with ian who
we get in touch with his
publicist or something publicist yes
everyone's got a publicist i love that
yeah
and he's too busy he only checks emails
once a week or something you know when
he comes out of the woods after a
successful hunt yeah i just liver king
here just in my successful
um
simulated hunt and uh talking to my my
pr guy ian
anyway so once we are once once uh once
uh liver king comes out of the woods
puts his head out we're gonna try to get
a hold of him get him but look at him
the funniest thing is like how nice his
neighborhood is like you could tell he's
just like living in like this fancy
ain't no problem texas neighborhood with
the king rancher out front
ain't nothing primal about his neighbors
probably love him they probably think
he's so funny he's like constantly
walking around back looks [ __ ] insane
sometimes he takes 120 pounds
what he looks like a christmas ham
yeah
sexy christmas ham
liver king is he's hot okay i'll say it
you think so he's not my type he's i
mean i i love if you have ever stepped
foot in a gym and have like dedicated
your a part of your life at the very
least bodybuilding you respect that
you're gonna respect that and you're
gonna find that attractive because
that's like you wanna [ __ ] liver okay
that's the main uh
no
no
you guys could build pecs to packs yeah
we're just gonna rub our we're going to
shoulders and
yeah liver king here i want him to carry
me like i'm his simulated easily bro
yeah she weight i'm 260.
that's pretty thick
i'm a big boy too city
i wonder how much i wonder how tall he
is because he kind of struck me as short
king no i don't think so i think he
might be tall i think he's a short king
that's why he's so obsessed with this
he's in his early 40s
this is a puffy you wrote this p you
wrote this liver king don't [ __ ] lie
you know what i mean how rich is he wait
let's see that light the light zone the
height zone and there's no height yeah
what the [ __ ] heights on what in the
height zone is this
go back is there height on there can you
control that height yeah that's what
that's how i found the height zone
uh what is his height well you tell me
that
nobody has his height
he stands taller than his peers from his
photos
oh come on that's
you can't do that height zone no
journalistic integrity here
you can't just like drop that into or
he's short
well i mean look at like uh one where he
is here
oh dude that's minimum he's on he's on
the assault bike and it's literally in
the lowest yeah yeah no okay that that
looks he might be short we go up to um
go up to the one where he jumps up to do
like the the muscle ups that one to the
third one yeah
let's see oh he starts at the top that's
weird that's strange he's he's careful
he's like wait wait wait wait wait but
like let him he'll drop down i want to
see wait it was just a picture no no he
he does most no but i know i've seen the
video obviously where have i this is
just a photo i think it was on tick tock
yo what the [ __ ] it's always real wait
maybe
look at his abs bro
that looks crazy awesome
it just it doesn't look natural to me
it's awesome really it's awesome yes
um
i mean you can kind of tell from
oh here is an i and a pool of ice
yeah look how pensive he is
you know ice isn't expensive but
when you have to dump a whole [ __ ]
bathtub full of ice that's that's ice
privilege
yeah
he's so icy um
let's uh go up to the one where he is i
think the video is like a little bit
above this
uh go up no no scroll up
scroll up scroll up scroll up scroll up
that third one i mean the first one on
this lineup here i think that's the
muscle up video maybe
liver king here
i just want to see like him around
household objects i feel like that's one
way to figure it out
maybe i got no [ __ ] audio
yep
because there's music oh
i mean i haven't used how tall no i
think yeah i think he's like
yeah i think he's tall
he could be i don't think he's five
three no shot no he's definitely like
six foot above six foot no he's not yeah
he is all right well anyway you know i'm
not impressed by liver king i am and by
his chain walking you know what i mean
uh i i know you brought your vest we
talked about it last time we were
talking about how much does this chain
weigh you were saying how much does
chain weigh like 80 pounds you were
thinking
um
i'm gonna
brought his his vest for me and this is
about a hundred pounds you'd say
um
i thought originally that it was only 80
but i feel like maybe it's a hundred
like it depends on what the small yeah
well
depends on how much those small things
weigh we can weigh it after i couldn't
put one of them in
hold on i'll show you just say they're
all in dude come on
you say they're all in and it weighs
100. we're not lying here
liver king might see this
okay hold on here
so
wait this you're in front of me
this is i believe this is like either
two and a half pounds or five pounds
okay
this right here five i think
it might not be five might be two and a
half ten okay
this
is a very
very heavy weight versus can they hear
us from here over here you got i mean
they can hear you about that you get
closer yeah okay what i what i have on
in my on my belly here
what uh a weight vest that i purchased
uh during the the beginning of the
pandemic the bay endemic
where i wanted to work out with weights
and i couldn't go to the gym so i bought
this and i did train in this a lot
actually what are you doing that to
train
just normal body weight stuff that you
would do becomes much more complicated
and much harder because you just you're
doing your your normal routine
kind of i would just do like push-ups i
would do push-ups in that thing with all
the weights squats with all the weights
yeah i would just instead of doing like
regular squats i would put this 80 pound
vest on
and do it like that
abe try to pick that up just to show him
how heavy that is i really want it well
abs
i'm sorry he's in beast mode right you
think he's going to have a hard time i
mean he's wearing my hair
athletic gear right now i just want him
to vow has a headband on this dude is
going to carry this like it's nothing
yeah look at that it'll be embarrassing
all right
he's mad at him ready
to fight get the [ __ ] out of here just
cut that out he's not
he's not come put it on me
what yeah
he's not the average uh human beings
he's got super strength
okay so
ethan you've completely vanished
like you're you're just gone you're in
the dead
there it is yeah there we go
so
this is the back part this is the front
all right
here i'm gonna put this over your head
you got it you need help oh my god oh
[ __ ]
it's like the thing you get when you get
an x-ray but
yeah it's gonna feel a little
hold on let me stand up oh [ __ ] can you
stand up yeah i got it okay here make
sure you push your butt forward you
don't want to [ __ ] your back up no no
push why'd you say that what do you mean
push your butt
yeah there you go athletic stance you
ain't stretch my hands yes squeeze your
butt athletic stance you know what's
crazy squeeze your butt oh god it hurts
my shoulders
you know what's crazy is the ice extreme
wearing that like just for the
for the exercise yeah you know what's
crazy is like for like 20 minutes i put
on 100 pounds
that's so much weight bro if i i could
like yeah that's a lot of weight to be a
fatty dude oh my knee my knee almost
buckled
no i'm okay oh my god maybe we should
take it off this is terrifying
uh i think that's 80 pounds for the
record
okay 100 pounds
what do you want
let me see
amazon i want to make sure that we get
it right like i want to make sure that
we get the
donkey
oh here it is yeah it's it's 80 pounds
100
okay it's 100 pounds
i mean you're handling it you're walking
around you're strutting yeah
no problem
it's 80 huh
i think so yeah the chain way that liver
king's got 120 pounds that's 120 yeah
he's the liver king for a reason yeah i
mean that's like hey you're doing you're
doing all right hit me with a take your
take your little birkenstock uh stocks
off and and do a do a quick
squat can you do it i'll try
i don't wanna i don't wanna i'm gonna
keep my ass knocked up okay so first of
all proper squat positioning okay we're
just getting up at this well i'm getting
i'm getting tired so it's time to have
the essence here i can do a squat okay
okay yeah that was a terrible point oh
come on bro oh look watch when you go
when you squat
when you squat
plant it on like bro plant it on your
heels plant it on your heels
you're going too forward you're when you
get up oh my god but i did the squat you
did do a squat what else you want me to
do it's dangerous
can you do a push-up with that [ __ ] no
no no okay you're
you're liver king ended up right yeah
stop a bullet
yes
100 that would stop a bullet there's
like awful plates in there
oh [ __ ]
it's hard to crack every time you do
that i heard it on the mic dude let's
take it off let's take it off yeah i'm
worried unless you want to keep taking
off me take it off quick
it's just it hurts my shoulders yeah
yeah after a while
that was awesome
you did it good congratulations ethan
see you soon liver king's not that
impressive bro i that's why i told you
that you could do that like i i told you
that you could easily do that that was a
lot for me
maybe i should get like a 20 pounder
when i do my treadmill you can take this
off like you can take the weights off of
it make it lighter that's cool it's a
[ __ ] though to take off and on dude i
felt like my knee was about to break
sideways your jacket from
in front of me
on the top match your jacket you move it
no it's your
move it okay
so
that's pretty good i mean i like the
idea of like exercising without having
to do anything but just wear it that's
kind of dope
i mean it's still
you can't you can't have it on too long
like it will because like i said it
compresses you and you're like
it gets it hurts your shoulders yeah it
makes it a lot harder to just like do
normal activities obviously but the
reason why i love it is because just
like you immediately noticed it's a
perfect demonstration of what adding
extra weight to your body when you gain
weight crazy bro you don't realize yeah
but you know what's interesting like if
let's say i put on let's say i'm at like
240 now and i used to weigh let's say i
put on easily 60 pounds okay so pretty
close to that
am i getting jacked by being fat
think about that yes you have more
muscle mass my legs got to be [ __ ]
like powerful yeah it's awesome
yeah so if i lose a bunch of weight real
fast i'll be i'll have like [ __ ] sick
calves yeah but the weight loss process
will also
you know the weight loss process will
also probably you know take my muscles
take some of your muscles out depending
on how you do it so fat people are the
strongest amongst us
well not necessarily
but that's what you said
well
your body does
need more muscle to be able to walk
around and do your regular activities
and you are kind of like walking around
with a weight vest on a huge one at all
times so yes you are stronger as a
consequence of that you build more
muscle as a consequence of that and then
ultimately because of that because you
have more lean muscle mass
you then can eat more
as well which is why
it's easier for someone who is
overweight to lose weight because their
resting metabolic metabolic rate is
higher because they have more muscle
oh interesting
how about [ __ ] that huh
you think my legs are stronger than
yours
no you weigh more than me yeah like 20
pounds i i weigh more than you i've been
working out for a lot longer than no
shot but i don't work out at all
um
the liver kingdom
look at the discord
oh yeah i threw it up two alphas right
there why you gotta make me look short
though cam i know he's like five nine
bro i would just measure me i'm almost
six feet tall
yeah i heard you guys did zach dirty
i didn't do zach nothing i feel like
that was that was a fake tape measure
so zach came in at 6-1 by the way and
when we stand up next to each other i
came in at almost six feet which
surprised me
so i'm almost as tall as zack wait
really yeah
okay he does present like a large man
like a very happy his tall stolen valor
i guess i don't know
people always think i'm like 510. and
then they meet me in person they're like
what the [ __ ] nobody thinks that about
you no i swear every time i do like i
went to the offline tv pop-up this
weekend
and like everyone was shocked they were
like wow you're so much bigger than i
thought you would be i'm like what did
you think i was
yeah do you think back in the day you
would have been like a turkish warrior
or something because you got like that
big
is there a lot of big dudes in turkey no
so you have that rare gene
where's your blood you must have like
warrior bloodline or some [ __ ] no i
don't know
i don't know anything yeah because
there's like big jews too like jews are
generally like look like me but there's
some like big warrior jews too that were
probably like you know king david's
[ __ ] kingsguard or whatever
i'm just saying there's war you got that
warrior gene your primal is what i'm
trying to say
you know yeah
all right like liver king
that's why i eat a healthy diet of
jujitsu yeah very funny cameron
no this cam didn't make this
that yeah but i know
mm-hmm but that's not a that's not a
jewish uh warlord
he appears to be a warrior and he
appears to be jewish so he's looking
like he's dressed up like a black
israelite
so he's got the drip down so you guys
want to talk about uh we've got okay
here
tell me which one you want to talk about
uh tucker says covet is making people
more feminine
love that we have maga rap about kyle
yeah i'm gonna written house you i don't
know what that is but both of those look
like fire we have steven crowder talks
to interviews no that one's boring
let's not do it is it that cause that
one's cringe as hell
it's just like steven crowder
just straight up sucking off kyle right
now i just like barely get over the fact
it's like even if you think kyle
rittenhouse should have been acquitted
right
you think it was self-defense whatever
i just don't understand the whole thing
of like turning him into a celebrity
yeah when you when you celebrate his
actions killing people when you
celebrate his actions you're giving the
game away that it wasn't about like yeah
you know the
justice system working like it was just
about just the justice of work in your
favor where you can like get away with
clapping you know people who you thought
were black lives matter protesters yeah
it was like what the [ __ ] what is this
deification of kyle rittenhouse he's
just some it's gross he's just some
teenager who shot people straight up
gross okay so we have uh the armed
christmas photos which are fantastic too
so so let's do let's do this okay i want
to see i want to see how we are becoming
more forcibly feminized yeah it's it's
awesome um here let's put it on sorry
liver king
but liver king has some ideas on that
too i would love to talk to him about
masculinity
is that liver cancer yeah he's liver
king he's still with us he's so dominant
he's still walking dominated many say
he's walking to this day he never stops
he never stops walking with that chain
on
[Music]
all right here's why we want to do it
and we invite him quality
yes we're going to go and climb that
hill
and here's why we want to do it and we
invite you to hold on hold on hold on
he didn't even say anything it doesn't
matter how you are ready
you can't be british and be like
masculinity it's like dude you're a
fancy lad okay automatically if you're
british and like a toilet i don't think
he brought it up i think it's tough all
i'm saying is if you're british okay and
you're a tory or you're toriya jason or
worse you're nigel farage you can't talk
about masculinity you're you're a fancy
lad it's it's tough just but the best
will in the world doesn't have that and
we've seen more u-turns in policy from
the johnson government than i've seen in
any government in my lifetime
and uh in a very embarrassing way oh
some of it's been shocking so somebody
who knows him told me and i i was
initially getting your take on this that
getting kovid
emasculated him it changed him it we it
feminized him and weakened him
as a man do you think that's well i
think by the way so his analogy is that
getting sick is inherently
feminine
jealous is feminine fellas
is it sus to get covered wait is he
trying to stop the dudes from getting
covered i guess i mean that's cool like
his audience like not me i'll never get
covered i'm getting boosted now brother
joe rogan well joe rogan got covered so
yeah and he's mr man one of the things
we have learned from covid
is people who are 50 60 70 80 pounds
overweight
tend to have fed very badly sure now we
didn't talk about it by the way he he
totally ignores his psychotic point
about kovitt feminizing and he goes yeah
no fat people get really sick from kovid
entirely just not acknowledging the
psychobabble of tucker i'm going back so
we can play on he was very seriously ill
for sure he was i think i mean one of
the things we have learned from kaiser
is people who are
emasculated him it changed him it we it
feminized him and weakened him
as a man wait wait feminizing is and
weakening him is the same
i think
one of the things we have learned from
covert
is people who are 50 yeah
but the virus itself
this is true
does tend to take away the life force in
some people
he's trying to get back to it he's like
come on let's talk about that
and he says it even worse here yeah just
tend to take away the life force in some
people i know this i mean it does
feminize people taking away the life
force feminization is taking away the
life force of someone being
crazy awesome what are you saying tucker
it's like just you know imagine hating
women that much holy [ __ ] it really it
is so interesting to see them talking
about they really want gilead they want
the
that hand the handmaidens tale in real
life like well they this banning
abortion i think they want ancient
greece they want to they want to butt
[ __ ] the homies uh and and be like yeah
it's not gay whatever brother you know
we're [ __ ] alpha warriors which by
the way is cool like you know
i'm on board with it good job but
tucker carlson would consider that the
greek hate women in the way or not it's
not even hate it's just like sub it's
like sub class
it's like they are
they are inferior they have this
biological function that we need but
other than that you know
whatever you know that's it it's just
there's a lot i see this a lot um on
tick tock and numerous other places
where like
i feel like men some men have taken like
hating women to such a degree that like
they just i feel like they just
literally despise women
so i always say like look man um not
saying that like all
misogyny and all of that comes from like
uh underlying
uh repressed uh
homosexuality or whatever but like you
should try some dick
you might like it you might like dick
and that's there's nothing wrong with
that you might explore dick i think i i
people make fun of me for this because
they think like oh stupid ethan always
thinks i think people who hate gay
people definitely are
vicarious like
people who hate gay people so much
are definitely bi-curious it's not i
mean there's definitely sought about it
there's definitely that just straight
are homophobic right like they just
[ __ ] despise and hate gay people um
but there is there's certainly they hate
gay people internalized homophobia
certainly does exist internalized
transphobia also no they hate gay people
because they hate their own urges for
[ __ ]
no it's not a 100 though like there's
that
i don't think it's 100 there's
definitely there are definitely not
about it they've probably browsed the
gay section at least once
i mean
this goes back to like sexuality being
fluid right it's on a spectrum it's
fluid
uh so because of that like you know
everyone is everyone can be a little
bi-curious sure um
like i've never i've never kissed a dude
or i've never been like i want to
[ __ ] kiss that dude you know what i
mean maybe curtis connor but like i've
never
i've never been like i want to kiss that
dude but i wouldn't rule it out i don't
give a [ __ ] i'll [ __ ] kiss a dude
kiss a dude in the mouth dude
would you suck a would you think about
sucking a penis
because that's probably more of a test
than the kissing the dude
would you take or
yeah okay so i mean i mean like i said
for the right person for the right or
the right thing
i'm not gonna rule it out what if
there's a suckable ass penis dude what
are you gonna do how do you get into
that situation you suck off the liver
king would you would i suck no no what's
his [ __ ] look like probably all [ __ ]
terrible probably yeah those that many
roids looking like looking like a tire
it's just
a tire it's just what like uncirculated
vascularity on his [ __ ] bicep
no but it sucks all the life out of your
penis and delivers it to your mouth i
don't know why you keep saying that i
think it doesn't triple
hgh if liver king is taking hgh by the
way let me know this affects the testes
no hgh makes everything larger like even
the [ __ ]
it makes your heart larger so i suspect
it probably makes your [ __ ] larger too
interesting yeah all of a sudden yeah
heath is like i think i might uh look
into this hgh business
a little bit of a little bit of and you
say it makes my heart bigger better
circulation
does it make my brain bigger no making
your heart bigger is not better
circulation oh okay making your heart
bigger is like literally directly
shaving like 10 years off of your okay i
thought it was like i was just thinking
that bigger heart would also pump more
blood into my penis no no no that's not
no no hgh is actually very dangerous uh
and that's why you know you said it
makes [ __ ] bigger though
dude you're gonna gamble on that
you're gonna all right let's [ __ ]
finish one clip what the [ __ ] is itself
this is true
does tend to take away the life force in
some people i know this i mean it
doesn't feminize people i don't ever say
that but it's true i
i love when he says
like no it's not you can't just [ __ ]
say something psychotic and then
like and then attach you know people are
afraid of saying this but it's true i
don't even it's such an abstract weird
psychotic [ __ ] word solid freak show
that even this ultra conservative
doesn't know how to respond to it like
watch but it's true i
look i think the virus did affect him
but i think let's be honest about it
it's it's the new wife isn't it i mean
it's you know carrie johnson or as she's
now [ __ ]
the new wife
was a new one which the historians like
dude look in the mirror very facial
expression very strong woman
uh
is
he's showing carrie johnson he yeah just
he did get married uh this year is she
hot can i see
boris johnson may or may not have had
sex with gallane maxwell
in college by the way actually there's a
very high likelihood damn she kind of
hot though boris is charming i mean he's
a [ __ ] weirdo i mean he's charming he
is i mean that's like that's funny
who boris yes he's got ottoman blood
yeah you don't know what that means but
oh he's ottoman right he's good he
doesn't look like it yes
you don't understand it's just the
turkish blood
we're doing we're doing fifth column in
in the uk we're taking over it's going i
mean islamic caliphate very soon lane
isn't a bad looking lady especially back
in her day
i can't acknowledge that she's
attractive because no you're right she's
a you know
a prolific groomer and and i mean people
say are kelly's attractive like i eat
breakfast
well yeah you're saying like no sexism
like no sexism if you're going to say
that like male 1 she's attracted sexual
abusers are hot then you should say
females you used to be hot
do you see the photo where she's giving
a foot rub to jeffrey epstein on the
airplane that just came out yeah matt
like it's so gnarly to see i don't know
why i find it she so she's also in the
footrope gang like that's his thing well
jeffy like
rubs
he he liked massages he liked like full
body massages and he liked very young
girls giving him those full body
massages by the way trigger warning i
mean obviously we're talking about
pedophilia
sex trafficking all that sort of stuff
but yeah he's uh yeah he was oh my god
from two angles why we have so many
angles of this
it came out during the trial right these
are yeah yeah yeah why did why do they
have two angles like he's he's a he's a
freak for obvious reasons but he also
loved like doc oh my god there's so many
photos everywhere yeah he had photos all
around his house
he also had cameras all around the house
too i wonder why no wait so i'm so
suspicious that he had cameras all
around the house wait she definitely
like putting her his foot on her boob
like this is not a yeah they were they
were dating so there's an ongoing trial
for the gillian maxwell uh a court case
at the moment where they're like trying
to oh there's someone next to him what
the hell wait who is this probably chris
tucker wait there's a guy sitting next
to him who is this guy i don't know some
[ __ ] billionaire probably do we know
who this is dude
oh man that's like if you're on the
lolita express you're either bill
clinton
okay
kevin spacey or you're like a harvard
professor
you know that's just like wait are you
sure are you trying to throw ding under
the bus no no no but pinker definitely
um
famous harvard professor stephen pinker
uh we know what you did
yeah you sick [ __ ] yeah
yeah so one last thing a merry christmas
from
the macy
family know what this reminds me of dude
like when you see like isis or whatever
or like
terrorist training camps with kids and
we all look on and hoard like oh my god
dude you know who just sent me that you
know who apache is
he's like a famous uh dj he's dope
either you better run shouts out to
apoche friend of the show he literally
just sent me
exactly what you're talking about i'll
put it in the discord group right now
here take a look
like right as we were talking about oh
yeah it's a picture of like a child
training that's crazy that just said
that to me yeah it's a picture of of
kids at an isis training camp holding
guns i'll put it i'll put in a discord
that was pretty good that was horrible
wow
that was slick i don't know if you guys
saw it
you guys can't tell but
i mean it's the old phone anyway yeah um
this is a psychotic you know i don't
care that you're american and christian
you're isis bro
you have kids you all cater
you have guns and you're in front of a
christmas tree you know jesus was all
about uh deadly weapons and uh
[Music]
you guys are uh [ __ ] in the head
you're
uh absolutely deranged
you have brain rot
this is
this is
in her family i wonder why both not
there uh is he in jail for showing
exposing himself to minors oh okay
because he did do that he did do that at
a bowling alley
lauren bobert actually as a matter of
fact and then laura robert was like i
love your dick tattoo let's get married
and here's isis training camp
and then here's loan beaubert at
christmas yep
the only difference is they're white
really
yeah have a nice house
yeah i mean they're not i mean doesn't
look like great conditions at least they
have a reason at least they're like yo
we are [ __ ] our conditions are
horrible yeah and we have a reason to be
radicalized not that i agree with them
you know but like yeah but like poverty
and and horrible conditions
these [ __ ] got no reason
they just hateful [ __ ] psychos i mean
not the kids they're just victims bobert
is absolutely [ __ ] deranged yeah
uh but but you see what i'm saying like
you got no reason to be that angry look
at this beautiful home you're in
yeah
nice rustic decor
jesus would have wanted us to have these
rifles
it's just as jesus famously said we
gotta kill that we gotta kill the arabs
and the mexicans
um i i the things like i like shooting
guns i'm a fan right hell yeah brother
and that's not even a joke like i think
guns are i i i
i own a gun
a semi-automatic shotgun bro for home
defense
i don't even have to pump it
damn just nice eight rounds
semi-automatic it clears that out real
quick somebody oh yeah don't [ __ ]
i'll tell you what bae yeah exactly
put eight big
eight melon sized holes in your body i
prefer not to own a gun but i'm but i'm
scared of psychopaths in the world yeah
yeah for sure i i totally understand
yeah so i'm armed um so
the thing is like i like
i i like shooting guns i've shot
automatic weapons semi-automatic weapons
i've done like many streams at the gun
range i go to the oak tree gun club
which i
enjoy
um i even get sometimes annoyed by like
some of the uh restrictions that they
put on to uh weapons in california for
example because they're stupid they're
not like
they're not actually preventing it like
what
like for example there's a butt stock uh
there's like a butt stock provision
where like
like the stocks that they have like the
handle that they have currently on those
ar-15s is um is one that you can grip
right like it's like a i guess what is
it called like a pistol grip or
something i don't know the full
terminology so all the gun weirdos are
going to get mad at me for even talking
about this right now they're really
it's not an automatic rifle 1588
anyway
but it's annoying because like
the way to get around the the uh like
pistol uh the pistol grip on an ar-15
they just like make these uh they make
these like weird grips uh attached to
the buttstock where
it is impossible to hold on to so you
have to hold on to it like this
with your hand like this
and
oh jesus
you know go ahead sorry the shoe fits
yeah exactly yeah but you know that sort
of sounds like kind of annoying um but i
do think that like guns should be
heavily regulated regardless and not in
a way where there's like these weird
loopholes where you can just like still
i went to a gun show and bought myself a
cannon
yeah there's no regulations that gun
shows by the way notice that she's the
only one without a gun which means she's
like all right kids
you got to take this photo for me now
yeah put on the guy i don't want to
mommy i'm scared shut the [ __ ] up and
hold the gun [ __ ]
[ __ ] tits she calls her eight-year-old
[ __ ] tits do you believe that wait
what's up with the there's like poor
trigger discipline on green bay packers
here not him he's got good well this
kid's ready to
shoot he's not
he's not um green bay packers is like
white knuckling
he's just he's not he's not but it's
still like he's he has anger he has
white anger uh
i i don't know i can't speak on that but
the one on the right the one all the way
on the right is also uh not maintaining
like uh you have to always you know aim
your rifle wait either on the ground
you're holding it up like this oh you
can't hold it up
no of course nothing's okay oh because
if he goes off in the air that's a
danger i mean yeah you always like this
is the problem with americans is that
like they guns are fun to shoot but
they're also you know murder dildos so
you're you have to recognize that you're
holding on to a thing
that can literally end life immediately
so
waving it around like it's a toy is per
pocket wait let me check the the trigger
to split on the macy's
trigger discipline oh they're all got up
well they're i'm assuming they're not
loaded but these guys that's isis that's
what i'm saying well they're they're
actually i don't think they have
magazines so they're you know smart that
they like took it off even then
it's it's good to why does she have a
uzi bro and this guy's got a straight up
like you got an m60 yeah and uzi you
know what's weird about this family is
like i would think these are otherwise
nice normal people like this
[ __ ] is out there i mean what
the [ __ ] bro what in the bible study is
this face
what the god damn sunday school but why
don't they have any optics like i don't
understand there's like now i'm
surprised because like normally when i
look at guns like there's like real
tactical right
there's like really terrible builds
where they'll put like a handle on top
of a handle before we put like a scope
on it or whatever
what the [ __ ] it's tactical baby yeah i
don't know america is uh diseased it is
sick it is cancered it is uh
i don't know what to say i mean you're
these people are absolutely [ __ ] in
the head that is an automatic
handgun that she's holding in the middle
the m60 and that means that they have
like a special kind of license that
usually like
certain gun stores have to be able to
both purchase and also
you know keep
uh weapons like that because that the
m60 is you know you can say it's like
it's like difficult to to use but that's
a that's a uzi that's an automatic uzi
like what are you doing
i love this this is a christmas card
best wishes christmas greetings
bro this is literally like come rob us
and take our guns like that's what this
photo says like we're we're just like i
i get the feeling this kid probably sent
this to all of his classmates
yeah that's the red flag he's like don't
come to school tomorrow jesus christ
even though definitely some some red
flags there don't come to school on
christmas
um mom's got the thompson which i
respect that's a it's an old classic
never shot one of those yeah this is
like the worst western movie ever like
the start of the worst western movie are
kind of messed up
but uh you guys first i mean let's let's
be honest i don't know why they i can't
like mom's dying quick
in a home invasion scenario i mean just
in a civil war what's he gonna do put
the belt up like you know what i mean
you're using m60 you need to [ __ ]
mount that you can't shoot this at the
top of the stairs yeah what are you
going to do
in a home evasion scenario you're going
to be the most dead they're all [ __ ]
no even she's [ __ ] that's the
automatic you're going to you're going
to empty out your entire you're going to
run out of uh bullets in a matter of
like
10 seconds there'll be some friendly
fire too one of them is for sure a few
of the other ones none of them have like
where are the pistols i don't understand
where is the shotgun so who are you more
scared of
in a civil war
hitting reaching him on the battlefield
the macy's or the bow birds
i mean
in a home invasion scenario
they're all of them are [ __ ] because i
don't see a single pistol there i don't
see a single shotgun there
they don't have good weapons for home uh
like for home defense
um
and they're these guys are totally
[ __ ] look at the long scopes they have
on there like what are you gonna do i'm
more scared of the macy's i mean these
guys probably put on camo they get their
duck they got like duck calls and [ __ ]
you know what i mean yeah they got like
survival kits i bet these guys [ __ ]
are a rough rider shot these guys
heartbeat she's a
all right dancing we're out of time yeah
arming yourself to this degree comes
from a place of cowardice for sure i
don't think you're like
i mean
i mean that the other family is
definitely collectors for sure because
you can't get that kind of arsenal okay
yeah maybe they just love guns yeah i
mean clearly they do
even though they are being kind of uh
you know irresponsible not as
irresponsible as the boberts though for
sure at least they took the magazines
out like that's
are there's really magazines in this
yeah what in the [ __ ] hell it's
probably empty but even then it's like
wait let's look at the dust cover on the
raiders
which one this one dust cover on the on
the what the [ __ ] oh the raiders they
all like you can i can't tell
yeah this kid is not wanting to be
involved yeah he's like what the [ __ ]
mom you gotta stop pulling me into this
[ __ ] i just wanna watch minecraft
content creators all right enough of
that let's go talk to
friend of the show dr ding to talk about
omicron
ombicrombie and finch
you're you nailed it twice and be cramby
yeah three times now speaking of which
um
we got a photo of their whole family
together
and uh here it is uh before we move on
yeah that's the whole family
wow
yep that's nice look at them they have a
lot
yeah they figured they have more in
common with isis than you know typical
americans so yeah they're starting uh
yeah they want it they want to establish
the islamic caliphate or will they want
to establish the christian caliphate
the
yeah what's the difference at the end
the pope is fake we're here to we're
here to bring the new pope
all right
uh thank you let's get ding on the phone
with us today is a air dr eric ding
friend of the show
you can follow him on dr eric ding at dr
eric ding on twitter
uh he is a prolific tweeter a great
resource for covid and
uh
health related stuff
hey doctor
nice to see you again
wow you guys got a fancy studio now oh
yeah the three million dollars we've
come a long way since our last uh
conversation kovit's been good to us
my god i see last time i showed up in my
underwear and this year yeah you weren't
wearing pants right
i was he was wearing a suit top and i
caught him without pants on oh my god
i know
i know we're just we're just that close
yeah we're good friends after that after
that well it's like it's cove everyone
was doing that you know
absolutely well it's just funny because
you hear people talking about it
and then
i just caught a little glimpse of you
know boxers crossing my legs yeah yeah
and i had i had to call you out doctor i
had you got you slacking all right it's
all right
all right so
i was gonna wear a suit for you but then
you know what i thought we're so laid
back that i'm still wearing my leather
jacket
absolutely
um dan are we good are we going yeah uh
we're rolling okay so let's just let's
just all right so uh welcome dr ding
friend of the show this is your third
time calling in i believe
right yeah it's been i've lost track
time space time doesn't exist during
this pandemic but happy to be back happy
to have you back this is my co-host
hassan
what's going on insane pecker you could
call it i'm a brave truth-teller and i
think covet is fake and uh you know
doctor i'm here to ask you some hard
questions today
that's all right
doesn't really rot jive with your bernie
shirt but that's all right no i'm
wearing this ironically he's a communist
all right so um dr ding is of course the
soothsayer the covet soothsayer
he was sounding the alarms on kovid when
everyone was saying it was
fear-mongering
and he was right he's always been right
he's dr ding and so i want to know what
the [ __ ] is going on with omikrom
omicrom
what the hell are we gonna do
oh my god you know i would say first of
all that uh
saying it right it's
pomegranate
omicron top battle you know you gotta
know the name of your enemy here
look we know it is gonna be bad we know
that it is about three to five x faster
transmission than delta some i actually
read another
expert that said it's 6x faster than
delta and delta
is twice as fast as the original so let
that sink in um
and some people say well oh it's it's
mild it's milder but you know what the
delta was 50 to double
more severe than wuhan so if it's milder
we're just back at wuhan
you know it's not that mild because you
know
the people who say mild they don't know
anything about epidemiology first of all
it's younger people getting infected and
younger people obviously hospitalize
less
so they didn't just for age uh we're
more vaccinated now than before didn't
adjust for that you know
more people are vaccinated this is just
for more people have been previously
infected
and yet yet despite all these things
hospitalizations are still shooting up
and there's like well it's not shooting
up any faster yeah but it's younger
people and it's vaccinated and a whole a
lot of people got infected before
and also deaths trail by a couple weeks
so you can't say that it's milder that's
nonsense that's there's there's this
hopium it's like a drug it's a opium of
hope
oh what about copium yeah we call it
yeah copy the left
yeah
some people call it copium but it's but
you know like good news is look i'm not
a female like i'm i don't drift anything
like i don't have a youtube channel i
don't have uh any you know widgets to
sell i'm not you know telling you just
buy my
vitamins like are you selling ivermectin
doctor that we can buy some dr dean
branded
he's sponsored by pfizer i know it you
brought this man on ethan i've never
taken any pharma money in my entire life
you know i buy every mechanism from you
15 years ago i was uh i was a
whistleblower against merck and pharma
companies hate me so i'm it's it's a
well-known thing dr ding's the real deal
and also you are you have tenure at
harvard as an epidemiologist no no no no
no no no i never was ten right but
you're you're i did a whole bunch of
different things yeah i got my doctrine
epidemiology
and then a separate one in nutrition so
people did you get your doctor from
harvard
yeah both of mine epidemiology
fake news that's right we're on the same
page on this right
a doctorate from harvard you guys have
no [ __ ] footing to question the ding
yeah guess what i got my doctor from the
medicine of bahamas and and uh yeah
my dog's a 300 mexican university yeah
it's a 300 course
we'll drop out guys i am a med school
dropout so let's get that i did fail on
some things in life all right don't stop
being modest go ahead
okay no but
end of the day um you know you can make
a like a really good media career out of
that you could just be like i left med
school because it was fake
and not because i failed i left it
because i couldn't take the sjw rhetoric
that's a good spin yeah yeah boom i
should i should be the next alex jones
and and hux and vitamins right sure um
no i actually became a faculty at
harvard medical school and then i had to
drop out of medical school it just [ __ ]
just got way too weird and you know life
is short you have to choose especially
and it's shorter than usual with a
covert
yeah yeah especially and it's also
making everyone
you know more peace actually yesterday
they found a study that says
the virus infects fat cells
so it actually worsens
covid because it also doesn't just
infect your lungs but also infects fast
cells and then it causes greater
response to sends you to more hospital
and so like we're actually creating a
vicious cycle right
covet is making us all
you know
a little bit bigger and it's actually
creating this vicious negative cycle
people not vaccinating is creating more
omicron
um and people we're not vaccinating
africa and this is like our karma for
ignoring africa
and
this is what we we deserve this it's a
it's a pandemic of a virus but it's also
pandemic of failed leadership
so let me let me ask you uh some
specific questions so
in your by your estimate it seems like a
lot of people don't know how to react to
the omicron uh threat people are
downplaying it people are not
understanding it it's very it's too
early to really even tell you know i
remember when we first started hearing
delta it was like ah who cares you know
and then all of a sudden it's a big deal
is that what you see happening with
omicron is in like a a month or two
months or everyone's like oh yeah
yeah it's it's bad like i cannot i feel
like this deja vu feeling where
you know people
said in january february march of 2020
that oh you're fear-mongering
it's not going to be that bad
we're in denial again we still have
people
you know on fox news saying oh this is
nature's vaccine it's perfect it's mild
and contagious and soon nature will
immunize us all that's the biggest
bull crap i've ever heard because it's
dangerous you know this is faster this
is like we're faster on transmission
than ever before delta twice
delta was twice as original this is like
three to five times more transmissible
than delta
and so we're talking about like on a
scale of infectiousness that you know
the wuhan can just original strain can
just go home compared to this
right and we're heavily immunized we're
heavily either previously infected and
yet it's blowing through vaccines um
with two shots three shots it's good get
boosters please oh okay that's
comforting
no no but you know most people haven't
because like they think oh pandemic is
over oh or like i'm i'm infected before
i recovered i got a positive antibody
test i'm good to go no the reinfection
rates are really high reinfection is
basically a kinder breakthrough it's
really high it's it's it's you're not
going to get the protection that you
think you have
and also
you know i hate to say it there's for
those
who previously got infected there's
something called dead men tell no tales
as in if you were vulnerable you had
already died
last year
and so that's why you think that uh you
the people who are got natural infection
has it better but no you're not
because the reinfection is gonna hit you
really hard we're talking about omicron
has three times the reinfection rate
of delta
so that's that basically means your
previous delta efficacy just dropped
like three quarters right there and the
antibody the antibodies are uh are are
inconsistent right like the antibody
development after uh like a natural
infection is inconsistent exactly
because it's highly bearable you could
have a tiny dose or have a big dose and
it's not stable and they estimate that
one in five people don't even have any
antibody response after a previous
infection they actually found them
and and so basically you're diluting
yourself if you think that oh
you know i got previously infected and
i'm okay no i don't think you're okay
it's and
and again the boosters
a vaccine booster is better than two
shots
and an infection so two shots in
infection
versus three shots that your booster
three shots is way stronger and they've
just shown last week that's good to know
i know so go get boosted like seriously
until they come out with the omicron
adapted uh variant nobody's taking that
you know you know nobody's taking the
omicron vaccine because at that point
yeah everybody's convinced that it's
just a griff no matter what nobody's
taking that no i don't you're 100 right
i think maybe you'll get
but you know for example i want to say
something like everyone who smokes
cigarettes because we have a lot of
experience in epidemiology cigarette
smoking everyone who smells cigarettes
knows that cigarettes kill you they
still do it but the moment that changes
their mind and they quit is when a loved
one dies
and
we are living in a society and we don't
see it we don't believe it until we see
it for ourselves yeah all right well i
don't know about what that happened
because neighbor has to die or my family
has to die before i take it seriously a
lot of us have this mentality and it's
dangerous and also the fact that i think
we have to relabel fully vaccinated as
three shots if we don't
people feel more invulnerable it's kind
of like when when we first installed um
airbags and seat belts people grow
faster because they felt invulnerable
when we had hiv cocktails people started
becoming more promiscuous because they
feel invulnerable and when we had
vaccines great but then they dropped all
their guard ventilation masks testing
distancing contact and they forgot them
all and it was like one vaccinated let's
go party nightclubs
and
that actually worsens it because you
could drop all your guard on everything
else and that's why we have such huge
numbers of outbreaks at christmas
parties and and and
comic con
uh anime convention i remember the
comments yeah
yeah last year yep
that was awesome i mean that was crazy
there was dr ding was tweeting about how
uh
comic-con was about to go down in like
seattle of all places where there was
like the first outbreak in america
and keemstar was like kim started a
story about how i was like being karen
trying to shut down comic-con i
literally went to pax east in
massachusetts in i think like the end of
january or maybe in the beginning of
february i went to the bernie sanders
rally
and i remember like
then there was a sense of unease where i
was like i feel like we shouldn't be
doing this like i had an obligation at
that point to do it it was my job you
know and i was trailing bernie on the
campaign trail but i i did feel like we
probably should not be doing this right
now
and then after that everything's shut
down anyway like i came back from
massachusetts and i was like everything
started shutting down
yeah it was crazy it was crazy we took a
lot of heat for that one let me ask you
this it sounds like omicron is so infect
and so
infectious
i keep hearing delta so like so
infectious even the rich the alpha one
was so infectious how infectious are we
talking about here now that we're on the
omicron stage how does this compare to
other uh normal illnesses in terms of
infectiousness
well first of all like alpha was only
like 30 percent more infectious 50
percent more effective delta is like 2x
more infections than the wuhan
word um but you know delta they say it's
more contagious than
than smallpox
um
you know
but you know basically delta had an r
naught r naught is like the virgin r if
you're like not doing any mitigation
like if you were completely caught off
guard you know delta has like six to
nine are not which means
three to five just for the layman that's
how many people a typical person would
infect right like basically one person
if if it's three one person infects
three three each of the three infects
three more each of the three in fact
three more the original wuhan we think
is like between three and five three and
four
delta we think is between six and nine
uh but if this is like
let's just say three times worse than
delta or four times worse than delta
we're talking about like
24 to 30. like it's that seems insane
like what is there anything comparable
to that no it's like first of all i
think it's it's a combination of the art
it's also like reinfection because
there's you can
in terms of contagiousness um
it's it's a higher viral load so every
breath you take every breath you give
i'll be watching you you give out way
more
viruses and every breath you inhale a
smaller amount will do its job when
previously you needed a bigger amount
so a bigger dose so it's all these kind
of things that adds up and there's
actually something that they think
actually might survive in the air longer
because it's more polar
like basically the
mutations are so many mutations that the
molecule becomes more positively charged
um
and because of that it actually it's
instead of
like when floating these droplets it
could easily get evaporated out if it
hits the wall of the droplet and then
but if it's more polar basically stays
on the inside
and survives longer in these aerosols
and droplets and that's why it stays
longer more stable airborne that's one
of the theories but is there any is
there any contagious diseases that are
this infectious i guess is what i'm
asking
like measles is in the teens okay um so
if if if it's really truly
three times more you know contagious
than delta this is gonna definitely set
one of the world records
um
and i think i think again we're lulled
into complacency we're right now in this
denial no way we've never seen something
so contagious before we're evasive
against the vaccine so quickly before no
way but you know what we've been saying
no way since last year everyone says you
know after the you know the spring wave
and the summer waves like oh we're done
we're herd immunity it's not coming back
boom winter weight and then after the
winter last year it's like oh we're
hurting immunity is not coming back boom
delta right and then like basically
everyone who said to where i heard of me
anywhere heard of me they've been wrong
every time like this sucker just keeps
adapting
it's a race
it
you know it's racing to survive
and the more warm bodies that you give
it the more practice it has
to evade and adapt
and if you give it billions of people
who've been infected already
then yeah the virus is going to find a
way remember jurassic park you know life
finds a way like the virus will find a
way it's
i got to stop you there don't they say
viruses aren't even living
well yeah but i'm saying
adaptation you got them you got them
good i just no but it's
you know it's called an analogy yeah
right apologies you're right i don't
know
stop using your two dollar words harvard
doctor
so are we ever gonna exemplify for you
are we ever gonna get rid of this thing
because it seems like we're headed down
a path of
uh covet world forever
no i don't think we're doomed or
anything like that
you know some people call me dr feigl
doom i'm not
i'm a very positive guy you know i i
find the good things in life but you
know i don't i'm also a realist i don't
ignore the bad signals
and i think the thing is like
people need to get over that you cannot
just rely on the single
like layer like if you have a castle you
can't just rely on your moat to protect
you you can't just rely on your outer
wall you have to like multi-layer yeah
ar-15s for the whole family
what i'm really trying to say is we've
relied on single-layer protection for
way too much right passwords are you
need now two-factor authentication we
need like two-layer uh like protection
against cobit you need a mask and you
can't wear flimsy cloth nuts you need to
wear the n95 or can 95 ffp2 i'll be
honest i've never worn that
then 95. i don't i don't think i've ever
worn an n95 really i have like one my
brother got one for me like in the in
like the middle of the pandemic and it's
still getting way better you you wear
n95 masks when you go out yeah straight
up well they're not that crazy it's just
a cloth mask with like extra layers it's
not like kind of insane face masks it's
the k 95 i recommend yeah kn95
but by the way uh if you wear a beard it
leaks
so both of you you got to shoot even
this you think is leaky
yeah like there's actually a [ __ ] i'm
going to die of it i'm not shaving see
how bad i look you know how bad i look
without facial hair i know what you're
talking about i think you look like a
babe i'm trying to be nice because
you're you're you're right you're you're
getting married you wanna
look sexy with a beard come on man i'd
rather die than shave this beard off
doctor that's right brother that's right
come to the right side it ain't
happening no but you see okay uh the
beard is uh is only a microcosm of what
i kind of want to talk about with
respect to like political uh action that
needs to be taken uh and uh more
importantly like uh
genuine changes that people still need
to live with in their lives do you feel
like and the resistance to that do you
feel like
we will ever get back to a point where
there is legitimately there are
legitimately like shutdowns in an effort
to like
uh you know prevent a wave i feel like
that's impossible at this point it's
like politically impossible there's no
motivation for it we're not australia
we're in a communist country like
australia
or new zealand
yeah so you know those communist
bastions of australia yeah that's right
okay
um so first of all i think we have
choice to make do we value lives or do
we value the economy
yeah easy easy answer done yeah
capitalism baby
that's right
yeah yeah because like here's the thing
like we
you know so many people starve to death
so many people
um
have no health care and die literally
because of no health insurance or their
health insurance or corrosive crappy it
won't cover their medicines
you know do we let people do that all
the time it's horrible in this country
and like we have these really weird
values that somehow you know people's
lives are meaningless in the face of you
know
of
of some the show most go on
which still by the way broadway they
have outbreaks
all the time i i think look we need at
some point obviously you know you have
to take personal responsibility please
get vaccinated
if you're not vaccinated please get
tests
please get
wear masks
please don't you know spew your aerosols
indoors at parties
without any mitigation but if you're
gonna do all that and we tell you all
these things
it's kind of like you know
smoking is bad
but
we try to raise the taxes on cigarettes
so we try to prevent minors from buying
it but in the end if you're still gonna
do it after we know it's gonna kill you
you know in our society
i don't know if we're going to be able
to ban cigarettes
you know or ban even bacon i don't think
so but do you want to ban bacon
well i'm out it causes diabetes heart
disease and strokes and colon cancer i'm
out pancreatic cancer
gout like you want to keep going kidney
damage like i can go on of all the
things that bacon can cause but i know
that if i say don't eat bacon or ban
bacon your audience is going to lose
lose their crap
i'm losing i'm i'm holding it in right
now but i'm there
actually there was the hamburger band
remember that whole talking point from a
while ago oh the green noodles
are alexander
wants you to stop eating hamburgers you
heard it dr dink says no more bacon you
just switched to more vegan vegetarian
or alternative protein sources he wants
us to eat soy you heard it here first
all right
it seems to me a doctor it seems to me
like what we're facing down
is a
like the way things are going you know
new york california blue states where
people believe in
science and support the government to do
more to prevent uh kovid
is gonna be better off and florida and
texas and you know mississippi whatever
the [ __ ] were they the governors are
like you can't even kids can't wear not
only
the governor straight up are like
you can't wear a mask in school we are
banning masks in school yeah
they're banning mandates right but yeah
but but what we're heading towards
basically
you know a lot of uh
of uh conservative deaths right
yeah we're having a burn through and
we've seen the huge differences in
biden voting versus trump voting
counties 3x right
it's it's more than 3x it's sometimes 4x
5x depending on how extreme of the tails
so is this good do you think maybe it's
good for like is this a good kind of for
the the democrats is like yeah let's
keep doing that let's just kill no no no
no no see i don't like that i hear a lot
of shot and freudia comments all the
time
i don't like that because first of all
there's dem there's lots of democrats
who live in texas and there's people
that you know i have relatives and
friends who are of both parties
and with the difference in this and
smoking is that smoking you kill
yourself
but well secondhand smoking is not
vaccinating you actually are are
are killing others around you and also
smoking yes you all secondhand smoke you
kill your neighbors and your family
members who are near you as well and
that's why secondhand smoking is banned
in restaurant we ban secondhand smoking
in restaurants and many other places
because
the aerosols and the cigarettes kill
others around you
but somehow you know by not vaccinating
that's when america went down and not
protection
you know oh aerosols kill other people
around you is somehow okay but
secondhand smoking is not like um
but ultimately
it's so work
ultimately
it's what it is
so let's just you know no it doesn't
work that way regardless because
republicans don't care about
republicans don't win elections
uh by virtue of having more people vote
for them in a democratic process they
win elections by stopping people from
voting regardless so they are already in
the minority in within the voter base
those margins are razor thin bro no but
it but it doesn't matter it still
doesn't matter because they will
increase the amount of stress as they
have through republican legislatures all
around the country as they have to
basically limit who can actually vote
and they'll still end up winning winning
and not only that but they also have
like provisions that they're passing in
certain republican states i think texas
is one of them actually where they can
by uh by the legislature
completely uh deny the will of the
majority even if uh god forbid a demon
rat communist wins uh a position they
can overturn it in the courts like and
and this is
this is what they're going to keep doing
so the idea that like republicans dying
is like good for the democratic party
let alone like is the democratic party
even good
it's not it's not happening like that's
not a real
real thing
right i agree first of all i think that
you know gerrymandering voter
suppression actually suppresses way more
votes so i don't think it's i think it's
a negligible strategy
so doctor what's the prediction for the
next six months
what's just be brutal be brutal about it
give me that [ __ ] that you used to give
me on twitter that got everyone angry
just give me the prognosis doctor i'm
not trying to anger anyone but i think
we're gonna have a
really really
bad burn through like a burn through
that we have not seen before and by burn
through i mean like
you know like hospitals
overwhelmed most people infected with
omicron by
by the next six months or a year
and
you know it's gonna be like
are you boosted if you're not you're
extremely vulnerable
and if basically you know you know how
like if you know a flood is coming and
you're telling everyone to go to high
ground
and everyone who ignores you
basically are going to be caught in the
flood
right now
i think everyone who's boosted is going
to be on high ground and wearing masks
n95 masks
and shave so that their masks actually
work pretty well
um
basically that is the equivalent of
going to high ground like getting the
premium masks protecting yourself with
boosters
ventilating buying hepa filters
um for your home and or uv uh
disinfection for your home's hvac
like all these
things them being super precautious
but those who don't who go to nightclubs
and who do all the dangerous things i'm
not saying they'll all
die but they'll get a lot of them will
get super sick and long covet we know
has
again long covet has effects of dropping
your iq points seven points if you're
what i see you yeah drop you get dumber
if you get covered i mean
that means you're getting brain damage
right
yeah exactly like wow you're
hospitalized but not ice you lose like
four points
in ice you get like slew seven points
equivalent but even if you never got
hospitalized you lose about anywhere
from two to three iqb yeah
that's what we needed republicans to be
dumber even dumber than they are that's
good that's dangerous but for reference
like a kid's lead poisoning you know
lead poisoning kids we don't accept that
in society right no lead points
have you have you seen pittsburgh or or
even you know flint michigan i i know i
know i'm saying theoretically for the
most part yeah no we definitely accept
lead poisoning children but lead
poisoning children is two points
that's it let's party people say lead
tastes good yeah i'm i'm sucking down
lead extra hard like
if you shift the average you know the
bell curve
two points
you know previously you had like what
two and a half percent of people over uh
iq of 130 um and similarly basically if
you shift it by two points that number
drops to almost like zero and similarly
you know in our society if long covet if
if long covert burns through so many
people
and everyone suffers like on average
like even half a point or one point iq
drop that's there's a huge amount of
like
you know mental health issues
and lots of organ damage and you know
also
we're going to be paying for this for
years like we're really screwed even if
there isn't a huge number of deaths the
long-coded effects are going to be with
us for years and so this is what i'm
saying everyone please dude that's scary
though the the brain damn you're gonna
get brain damage and got covered ian do
you feel dumber
absolutely [ __ ] in all right all right
i didn't want to say it but i look i
just um i don't think i don't think like
we're gonna take the systemic
precautions so what you're hyping up
basically is like individually
protecting yourself and your loved ones
which you know strikes at the core that
americans understand we're very selfish
country we're very selfish individuals
everyone's an individualistic person
yeah so that's a good attitude to have i
guess um
i totally do see that uh you know people
who are
uh people who
kept up with the latest uh you know
in what's going on and with the covert
world uh definitely feeling fatigued
and and uh being a lot more skeptical
every time there's a new variant it
certainly doesn't help
that uh there are so many media outlets
uh especially on the right and in
independent media that are saying like
oh they're just making up fake strains
now they're making up fake variants to
like keep the coveted market going
ironically that is what they themselves
are doing which is you know spreading
misinformation and you mentioned
cigarettes right
we have a lot of
restrictions on
what you can and can't show with respect
to cigarettes in mainstream media
obviously back in the day we had you
know
five out of ten doctors recommend camel
like that was that we had doctors
promoting cigarettes billboards yeah we
had billboards all that sort of stuff um
the reason why uh the secret analogy is
actually a really interesting one from
my point of view
the reason why
this is so much worse is because like
you have
it's like you have an entire
50 of media uh both independent and also
major media that is promoting the
benefits of second-hand smoking and
saying that like smoking doesn't kill
and everyone that is saying smoking
kills is a [ __ ] and a liar and a
communist they're saying that the
second-hand smoke is actually good for
your lungs yeah yeah exactly
so yeah so it's it's
significantly worse uh and somehow
believing that cigarettes are bad
uh is
and accepting that cigarettes is really
really dangerous for you is apparently
weakness
right like the analogy today
in fact uh you know smoking doesn't even
cause cancer that's just big chemo
yeah well that's big chemo um
and stuff man yeah that's that's crazy
out there but honking doesn't cause
cancer is big chemo that's why we need
to go to another big pharma uh
manufacturer to do the vapes instead
that's the real cure
but i think i think what you guys are
touching on is important at this point
all we can do is protect ourselves and
people around us hasson you got to get
boosted yeah i know
you want to get that boost before the
amy cram lowers your iq by the way
aim at cream and b crayons no that's
cool i i give myself a brain run every
day i have stream on twitch so you know
i'm
i'm actively
hurting my brain okay all right well
then if you don't you know
no what's another five points yeah
you're right i just haven't had time
between friends what's another five
points yeah yeah the ambiguity and finch
man that's it's a slippery slope to
who whatever like
you know i believe in a lot of
individual freedoms but at the same time
i do not for the record
really during a pandemic
on that people everyone just like needs
to like drop their egos and just work
together and
theoretically kumbaya to work together
but
we know that there's so many sabotaging
governors and legislatures that's going
to prevent that in bad media do you uh
have a reckoning when this thing is over
of how many people they honestly killed
no shot there will be no reckoning those
people are going to run the country and
they're going to continue running the
country i doubt that greg abbott or ron
death santas ever get any sort of like
punishment oh and i'm sure i'm [ __ ]
sure as hell that trump's going to win
the the republic
is dying like
yeah
um so yeah no i i think the future does
look bleak uh so yeah protect yourself
protect your loved ones get boosted i i
will get boosted as well dr dink do you
think asking people to wear masks is
equivalent to tyranny
uh
probably not i'm gonna take a
hard no on that how would you compare
wearing masks to putting uh minorities
into death camps
well death camps is an extermination
mass doesn't exterminate you
okay mastercard as a liar why'd you
bring them all in
that's not what they're saying on the
right this guy's a liar no it's yeah
it's the the holocaust is
holocaust was bad because you know uh
everyone was uh inoculated and immunized
that's that was the bad part denied
exactly exactly
george washington technically mandated
everyone get inoculated against the
smallpox for his first year he was a
coward yeah that's why i'm a british
monarchist actually yeah we still we
were
i'm so conservative the queen yeah yeah
the the yeah the george washington and
the uh you know the american reaction
area yeah that's real i mean there are
people like that but you can you know
they don't actually you can't criticize
george washington on the right you know
like that's their patriot like yeah
george washington they don't care
there's like they they literally will
never talk about that or avoid it it
doesn't matter it's like saying you're a
originalist or constitutionalist it's
like no you're just a reactionary you're
just uh couching that under like some
sort of intellectual analysis
like the thing about it during wartime
right a national emergency
the republicans support the draft the
draft is
taking away your freedom you must go to
war you can't do what you want you are
drafted go to war
and
in certain ways we're we're kind of
conscripting people to
to really
save other people's lives that's a good
analogy i like that we're drafting you
to put a [ __ ] mask on your face yeah
like we're it's a national emergency and
to protect this the sanctity of this
country and this health and wellness of
this country and economic vitality of
this country wear a mask like like you
know they believe in patriotism and so
in many ways it's patriotic to serve
your country patriotic to sign up don't
be a dodge or draft dodger remember it's
like be a patriot don't be a like to
serve your country once upon a time on
the right that was like a good thing but
like now how come being patriotic and
protecting your neighbors is a bad thing
uh because patriotism is defined by
whoever uh is the most like reactionary
or nationalistic uh
aesthetically it has nothing to do with
like true patriotism or i don't know
like the german kind of patriotism or
even the chinese patriotism of like
uplifting uh
and and
trying to make the entire country
prosper uh it's not about that at all
it's just whatever reactionary
politicians have decided is patriotic
which is owning a gun wearing snakeskin
leather boots and a big belt buckle and
saying
even though you have a [ __ ] mba from
harvard and you know or a law degree you
know that's like that's the reason why
ted cruz who
is is not even remotely close to the
working class can act like he's more
working class and more patriotic and
more american than alexandria
ocasio-cortez because she's brown and
she's from you know new york doctor my
friend is trying to radicalize you
i'm just no i mean that's not going to
happen he's
do you think the heart you have
something to say because he goes to
harvard well i don't think i'll be able
to radicalize someone who is like a
a figure in mainstream media who has
like well-established positions can we
radicalize you dr dane is there a chance
radical okay let's test it i mean he did
he did he did specify that he's are you
for medicare for all
oh yeah of course okay keep testing him
see how radically he is okay good we're
gonna give him a rad test
okay i mean i don't know what the brad
test okay doctor dink and
the you know the sunrise movement pledge
for you know green green energy and
everything how do you know about unions
okay what do you what do you think about
unions
i'm pro-union of every sort other than
police unions okay oh
pretty good dr ding a radical i want to
live in a world of of star trek where
you know like okay that's communism
straight up communism where you know
money
you know the pursuit uh to better
ourselves is a pursuit of humanity
rather than a pursuit of acute
accumulation of wealth yeah would you
say you would like to live in a
stateless classless moneyless society
i believe we should live in a world
where everyone can better themselves
without having to worry about a lot of
the he said
he said that hold people back i don't
like things that hold people back thank
you as always watch out for that omicron
protect yourself get those boosters
and
uh let the bodies hit the floor
oh god
yeah yeah i wanna i wanna be able to
come back and i wanna be able to see you
still healthy and not slurring your
speech because of some
covet infection
okay absolutely please please everyone
stay safe please shave so your mask
works even better all right
wow okay all right dr dink thank you as
much as always and uh you stay stay uh
keep doing your thing okay keep keep
writing the good word out there all
right
thank you to
the ding i call him affectionately
uh
you know good guy
great guy highly educated
very credible at dr eric ding on twitter
here i'll save his prospects uh he
doesn't agree with me on anything don't
worry oh yeah he disavows everything he
disavows everything about me he told us
off the show he said guys we i disavow
it all
yeah it's all i'm a capitalist safe he's
safe now i'm a capitalist through and
through i do not deviate
well that's
show good one a lot of fun
it's
the
we lived we learned eyes had some lows
we lived we learned we laughed and we
loved we did love yeah
a lot of love
live laugh learn love did you say learn
yeah you did um
when are we off
when are we off like when do we not have
an episode
dan
next week
we have we should probably mention that
right yeah uh we mentioned on one of the
other shows but we should mention it
here too we're going on hiatus for uh
the break
in a couple weeks from now so there will
be uh
two more episodes no wait just one more
episode before the break oh my god so
next week will be the last episode and
then we'll be on uh break and then we
come back and what january something
uh yes end of january this is communist
by the way communism is when you take
long breaks that's right
and the longer the more communist it is
yeah we're off uh until
um the whole show is dark until the 16th
of january so the whole show is dark
that's interesting
we're going into stealth mode that's
right
that's right
this is what's right this is when you do
the steroids
just come back all year [ __ ] peeled
all right
i'm down
three weeks you think i can make a
transformation in three weeks
i mean i'd have to stop eating
straight up no food no fap no food yeah
never drug off semen retention
like our good doctor jordan peterson
demands
um you know that was crazy how dr ding
was like keep all your semen he's like
yeah that was weird that he was known
fab too i guess you know i was like wow
maybe he's a truth teller after all i
was i misunderstood
it was just totally out of pocket for
epidemiologists but yeah he was saying
keep every drop harvard approved nofap
all right
so we'll be back next week
and uh well we'll tell you goodbye next
week and we'll get all sappy about it
but until then
we're still here
for now
unstoppable
indomitable impregnable that's right
real patriots
boosted except hassan doesn't isn't it
boosted are you boosted i'm boosted i'm
about to get boosted
get boosted boys we can't lose any of
you yeah none of you should die dakota
no no we need every [ __ ] viewer
we don't want you turning republican by
losing iq points right
[Music]